c'est au palais de saint jean près de
nos fleuves dans la campagne anglaise
que la reine a convoqué le prince
charles ses fils william et harry et
michael moorcock était en conférence
téléphonique car elle est au canada
que s'est il passé que s'est il dit en
tout cas cette réunion de crise a porté
fruit
buckingham palace publié un communiqué
de la reine peu après même si nous
aurions préféré qu'il reste membre de la
famille royale à temps plein nous
respectons et comprenons leur souhait de
vivre une vie plus indépendante puis la
reine ajoute al rimi guen ont clairement
indiqué qu'ils ne veulent plus dépendre
des fonds publics
nous sommes entendus pour qu'il y ait
une période de transition où le couple
passera du temps au canada et au royaume
uni un communiqué décortiqué par la
presse
on ne parle plus du duc et de la
duchesse de ce sexe mais de verrerie et
mégane les médias britanniques y voient
déjà un message clair le couple est il
en train de perdre son titre d'altesse
royale se demande le daily mail un titre
important puisqu'il leur garantit les
services de sécurité entre autres et les
voyages gratuits
le mexique se fera dans quelques jours
titre le sam à la question qui va
assumer les frais de sécurité du couple
au canada nous voulons toujours être une
bonne partenaire de les pays
khroma loi mais en ce moment nous
n'avons pas considéré
langer mais cette décision du prince
riri de se retirer n'est pas surprenant
dit le biographe de la princesse diana
le prince harry est liée à la monarchie
dit il
mais cette institution le fait beaucoup
de mal n'oublions pas qui s'est toujours
battu contre cette monarchie et ses
médias en octobre dernier le prince mari
poursuit les journaux à sensation il
leur reproche de s'en prendre à sa femme
meghan markle est souvent décrite comme
une arriviste et récemment un animateur
de la bbc a comparé leur fils un singe
sèche-mains la manche jusqu'à venture
elle aurait dû savoir dans quoi elles
s'engageaient dit il regardez ce qui est
arrivé avec la mère d'harry la princesse
diana
et c'est justement pour cette raison que
le couple aurait décidé de prendre ses
distances
ici à zeewolde eggers guise radio canada